let's say that we have some country
let's call it utens landia that can only
produce one of two goods or some
combination of them so it can produce
forks
and it can produce or it could produce
spoons
and so this axis is the quantity of
forks this axis is a quantity of spoons
and let's say that if it put all of its
energy into forks well it would produce
that many forks and no spoons and but
then if it tried to focus some of its
energy some of its resources on spoons
well then it would produce fewer forks
and then the more spoons it produces it
will produce fewer and fewer forks all
the way to the point that if it only
focused on spoons well it could produce
that many but then it would produce no
forks
what this curve is and we touch on in
other videos this is the production
possibilities curve for our country of
utes utense landia that makes utensils
and obviously most countries are much
more complex they don't only produce
some combination of two things but this
helps us this is a nice model for
understanding what countries might be
capable of
now one way to understand this
production possibilities curve is it's a
it shows what can be efficiently
produced by this country if it put if it
efficiently utilized all of its
resources then it will produce some
combination of forks and spoons that sit
on the production possibilities curve so
this point right over here this
combination of spoons which would be
that many spoons and
that many forks this combination over
here this would be efficient that point
x would be an efficient production for
utense landia so at this point right
over here let's call that point y
now what happens if utensilandia goes
into some type of a recession for
whatever reason it's not able to use its
resources as efficiently and we're
talking about resources we're talking
about land we're talking about maybe
it's factories we're talking about the
materials it has maybe it's labor well
in that situation let's say it was
operating efficiently here but then the
recession happens and so then it
operates right over here let's call this
point right over here z this would be an
inefficient use of its resources sitting
behind the production possibilities
curve so this is in
efficient
just like that and so one question you
might have is well what about points
that are beyond the production
possibilities curve like point let's
just call that point a right over there
what about that point
well unless you have more inputs unless
you have more land more capital more
labor if you don't change the resources
here this is actually going to be an
unattainable point for utenslandia
but let's say you really want to reach
it how can that happen
well you can actually have investment or
you could have more land or more labor
so let's think about that scenario
so let me draw the two axes
so that's my fork axis that's the
quantity of forks that utensalandia will
produce in the year
this will be the spoon
axis right over there and let's draw our
original production possibilities curve
so i'll try to make it look pretty
similar to what we had before so that's
our original production possibilities
curve another way of thinking about it
is it's showing the trade-off between
producing forks and spoons you can
actually
think about what is the opportunity cost
of producing an incremental spoon in
terms of forks how many forks do you
have to trade off because remember
there's scarcity at play you don't have
an infinite amount of metal
to produce things with an infinite
amount of labor an infinite amount of
factories
but let's say utenslandia they are able
to get some more land on which to build
factories maybe they build some more
factories so capital goes up maybe some
people migrate to utensalandia so in
that situation you would have growth so
this would be and your production
possibilities curve would actually shift
outward
so here we are showing let me make it a
little bit
we are showing a situation right over
here this is still a production
possibilities curve but we're showing
what happens when you have growth and
once again what are the drivers of
growth well this could be your the
amount of land that you have goes up the
amount of capital that you have goes up
capital could be things like
factories it could be machinery
you could have people more people are
able to help produce the spoons or forks
you could just have
better technology for producing spoons
and forks sometimes people will even
talk about entrepreneurial spirit that
people are able to figure out better
ways of combining these resources so
that you could produce more spoons or
forks
but let's imagine now the other scenario
let's imagine a scenario where
utenslandia gets into a war with
platelandia
and platelandia
sends their bombers in and starts
destroying some of the factories of
utensilandia and so what will happen in
that situation so before the war this is
that production possibilities curve for
utensalandia
but now because of the war maybe
platelandia is able to take some land
from utensilandia maybe it's able to
destroy some of the factories
and other forms of capital maybe people
flee utensil india so there is less
labor
and maybe for whatever reason they can
support less technology
or they forget how to use some of their
technology because the war is so long
and protracted
well in that situation
your ppc you would see contraction
and contraction
i could depict it let me shift my ppc my
production possibilities curve inward
just like this so this is a situation
where we are seeing contraction
so big picture here your production
possibilities curve is exactly what it
says it is it shows what can a what is
the potential combination of in this
case goods that this nation can produce
and if you're sitting on the curve it
shows that that nation that country is
efficiently using his resources if
you're sitting within the curve it's
inefficiently using those resources and
if you're on the right of the curve or
beyond the curve
well that's a situation where if you
don't change the inputs all else equal
this would actually be unattainable the
way that you actually do attain get to
points beyond the curve is by shifting
the curve itself by having more land
more capital more labor or more
technology which we see in this middle
scenario